congratulations thank you so much oh my
God no no no no me first my jaw just
dropped when you popped up on the screen
because my God is stunning like calling
me up already what come on I even get
stuck in my makeup yet
I was just gonna say you wore the like
perfect onesie for like the big brother
Queen
One Crown to the next let's go thank you
yeah you just need a Tierra on top of
there which you are familiar with
um you made history tonight I think
women all over are just so happy for
this to happen what does it mean to you
to be the first black woman to be to win
Big Brother it means literally
everything and then some to me I came
into this game with the mission of being
the first black woman to win Big Brother
I knew it was possible it felt
impossible many times in this season
knowing and learning the history of the
game from watching it and understanding
that black women were very often
ostracized and bullied and belittled in
different ways and to be the person who
will who has
fully exemplified all of those things
and gone through the fire this season to
still come out Victorious it just means
that I'm breaking down the door so that
more black women like me can play the
game in their own way they don't have to
be an example and I was willing to be
the example so they can have freedom
and then not only did you win your
America's favorite so I I don't think
you understand how much like the entire
audience is in love with you that
surprise you it shocks me because I was
positive you girl you don't even know I
was like I'm a fashion girl coming into
the franchise a couple Seasons before
like these fans are not gonna want me
anywhere near Big Brother Big Brother
fans want true hide like die hard fans
in here I'm just a pretty girl looking
for a good time I just knew that the day
that headshots were released and
preliminary interviews were out I was I
knew would be like get her out of here
we don't water she's not a true fan and
to very quickly from what I'm learning
now doing his interviews to very quickly
amass the group of I mean this fan base
again going back on Reddit and Twitter
and trying to understand who they like
who they didn't like it's very split
often like there's very strong
um rallying behind some people but it's
usually pretty divided over a season so
to be finding out that
apparently was the Taylor show this
summer like I I'm not too worried about
it I'm surprised very surprised that I
could get that much love but thankful
and grateful do you feel like you've
been Vindicated after like all you've
been through in the house let me tell
you something when the leftovers came
together that's when I felt more
Vindicated because now I find a group of
people that saw me as me they understood
that I was not the stereotypes already
placed on me and I got the other things
that I was being accused of were not
true
um but also I had a moment with Nicole
just after the show I gave Daniel a hug
right after the show and yeah they just
they
from what I'm understanding Nicole more
so are willing to own their stuff and
all I can ask for people to do if they
have wronged or hurt people is to own up
to what they did just the same way I did
all season
um for smaller things that I was accused
for but just own what you do and then
there's space for recovery and
ultimately it sounds like I am being
Vindicated it sounds like 800 000 worth
of indication to me yeah
and obviously the show man's what we're
all interested in where do you think you
and Monty say that or stand now
especially after you beat him
I mean that was his choice I will I will
give him out to some credit he said that
if he were to lose the game he would
want to lose to a black woman and sorry
bud but you know you manifested that one
so as part of the snowman's I think
Monty and I are going to be good friends
for a long time I don't know if there's
a romantic connection there that'll last
long term but okay whatever happened
he's gonna be a good friend for a while
okay and obviously I came up with this
idea that I feel like you should do a
Super Bowl commercial for chips
and if you did what do you think that
would look like oh it'll look like
people trying to bother me all day
yelling whatever remarks and I just
walked by unbothered crunch crunch
nothing's going to phase me I have my
chips and I'm in my own world my fantasy
land so Taylor chip Reigns again
I feel like I need to pitch this to like
lays Doritos yeah
probably just lays because I was more uh
Super Bowl this year now so
it can happen
commercial too I feel like that's the
perfect pairing the two queens
please her and her perfect little baby
oh I cannot wait
all right and then so my last question
obviously Turner was all about the
busting And discussing which I'm just
learning because I'm a millennial and
not a gen Z yeah
so I'm going to give you a couple
scenarios and you tell me if it's
busting or discussing please okay so uh
living in the Big Brother house Boston
uh the Big Brother comics oh a super
mega busting that's like a YouTuber all
right the zingbodzing super mega busting
I'm the [ __ ] of the season the ice
queen of the season I will take it give
me that Crown give me this Crown I got
my pageant crown I'm just raking them up
let's go super mega I love it I love it
um meeting Julie
are you kidding me oh my God okay I hope
I don't get trouble for this Julie came
to take pictures and she had on her Ugg
slippers and I was like that's how you
do it clean put the slippers on like yes
that is what we do now
yeah 100 I I love that she did that all
right uh Daniel's freak out ah
disgusting
which one
okay and my final is the love triangle
between you Monty and Joseph I mean
as far as playing with people's emotions
which I was not doing that is just not
the case but as far as having options
that's pretty busting if you ask me I
don't know I agree with you pretty
blessing to me